[Music]
nick cannon and bree tiacy are now proud
parents to a baby boy and reveal his
unique name while documenting their
intimate home birth as you say i like i
love children i want to i try to
document everything like that their
son's moniker was shared in a vlog the
model posted on youtube where she gives
fans an inside look into her pregnancy
and natural delivery
[Music]
i am
huge
[Music]
huge
so stupid any day now and when bree
finally went into labor nick stuck by
her side through it all
[Music]
after the two welcomed their son they
showed off his nursery see that sign on
the wall that's the little guy's name
[Music]
let me see
just let me see
hey
legendary
hey hey hey
yep his name is legendary love they even
had it written on this beautiful cake
but ahead of giving birth only e.t was
invited inside the nursery for an
exclusive peek and brie she shared why
they chose the strong name for her
firstborn i also notice over here you
have the library already lots of reading
to do right lots of reading and then
legendary love yes
yes i think this just you know plays
into our relationship so
i loved that legendary's arrival marks
nick's eighth child of course the tv
personality is also father two
eleven-year-old twins monroe and
moroccan with ex mariah carey
five-year-old golden and one-year-old
powerful queen with brittany bell
eleven-month-old twins zion and zillion
with abby dylarossa and his late son zen
whom he shared with alyssa scott who
died at five months due to a brain tumor
with a family that big breed told et why
she decided to start a family with nick
i've never really put that much effort
or attention into anything so when it
first started happening i was like i
don't understand why everyone's so
concerned like why are you upset about
what happens in my household
um but for me i really just kind of it
doesn't actually genuinely affect me um
i understand people's
side and they're used to their
conventional relationships that's what
we're taught that's what's instilled in
us
um but stuff like whatever you want to
call this has been going on forever you
whatever relationship works for you and
for nick making time for all his kids
comes easy it's something he talked to
et about earlier this month it's not as
difficult as people think it would be
but i understand because it's a very
unorthodox scenario but it actually i
mean i dedicate probably
my entire day to my children luckily
we're in a world where
my life and i think i might have said
this and was misquoted before but i was
like i get i'm blessed with the
opportunity i get to spend more time
with my children
every single day because of my world and
my business my lifestyle so and now that
includes little legendary love congrats
to nick and brie on their bundle of joy
[Music]
you